as we'd like to mix pop culture
television movies music with the sports
world sports is as pop culture as
anything else so if you're just somehow
watching us for the first time we've
been on five plus years and I'll be very
honest with you open hoping to get this
this the next guest on this program for
those five years and I am thrilled to be
turning the phone line right now and
find the Emmy Award and Golden Globe
Golden Globe award-winning actor from
Blue Bloods currently airing in season
ten Fridays on CBS at 10:00 Eastern time
the actor Tom Selleck how are you Tom
I'm great thanks for coming I am better
for talking to you I appreciate you
calling in to the show we just had the
15-year NFL veteran Carson Palmer on he
said he wore a Tigers cap as a kid
because you did on magnum p.i and he
couldn't name a single Detroit Tiger
from the team so you were well you know
I'm an FC alum and obviously an SC fan I
didn't know that but what a great career
he had cars Palmer no doubt about that
so I know you want to share some stories
about the great Al Kaline who passed
away last week so I will give you the
floor Tom I'm one on who Al Kaline was
to you well look he was my my boyhood
hero when I was my dad put my brother
and my mom and I in a car and drove out
to California took a risk and we started
a life out there but his promise to my
mom was she had eight brothers and
sisters was I'll get you back there
every summer so every summer we pile
into mostly a 53 Pontiac and and drive
straight through because my dad was
working on Commission so we only had
like a week in Detroit and he had to get
back and he was in real estate so anyway
um I was a huge tiger fan we had no
Dodgers in LA till I think what was it
57 so I sound like an old-timer don't I
well I am so we had the the LA Angels
and the Hollywood stars where our minor
league baseball teams but I was a tiger
fan
and somehow I got the Tiger locker room
and met Al Kaline along with Harvey keen
and a lot of pleasure that was obviously
a big deal as a very young kid he just
and and occasionally the Tigers would
get on the game of the week and in those
days you that's all the baseball major
league baseball we got to see in LA
you know once a week that was the game
of the week and and that was it so
occasionally I got to see him play I
just admired the way he played and the
more I found out about him the the more
I admired who he was he wasn't any kind
of a showboat he was a great athlete and
but he he let his his playing and as his
character speak for itself and I always
that was kind of the mindset I hopefully
and inherited from him there's a there's
a story rich joe and i thought it was
one of those mythological stories maybe
like Babe Ruth pointing and calling his
shot
who knows wood whether that's true well
I always heard this story so I went to
spring training with the Tigers to
prepare for a movie mr. baseball sure no
and Sparky who I knew by then because I
worked out with the Tigers a couple
times had come to spring training it'll
help you prepare so I went for two weeks
first night I go to dinner with Sparky
and and Jim Campbell who was the general
manager of the Tigers for years sure and
I said I've heard a story you know and
you got to tell me is this just a myth
or something
evidently $100,000 was the big mark for
the our best baseball players in those
days and that's what Mickey Mantle and
who else was gettin sure I'm sure anyway
yeah I'm sure a mandolin although
although all the top players back in the
day we're getting at Tom
well Nick no Mickey Mantle was get that
was it okay and so basically I said this
was the days where players came in and
negotiated their own deals they didn't
have agents or anything so outcomes in
the end of the season the beginning of
the next and they say you're as valuable
to us as Mickey Mantle and we're proudly
going to give you a hundred grand next
year and Kaline said I had heard I don't
want it I didn't have a good enough year
I didn't hit 300 he said next year I'll
hit 300 and you can give it to me but
not this year and I asked Jim Campbell
if that was true cuz he was in the room
and he was yeah it's true he said and I
wouldn't let me tell anybody so all year
I got beat up in the press not giving
him what he was worth yeah what what I
think is important to remember about Al
Kaline and what I hope his legacy would
be is he just that that was very typical
of who he was and and who he was is how
he played and that's not always a case
anymore no definitely no I don't think
you you can imagine Al Kaline flipping a
bat I don't like people who flip that's
maybe I grew up in a different sports
world but I I've always believed in all
sports that if you demean your opponent
you trivialize your accomplishment it's
it's it would be nice to see that legacy
continue and he's certainly my hero
still and the more that story gets out
there the ironic thing is I tell that to
people who remember that generation and
all and they're kind of in awe if I tell
that story to kids I do a lot of work
with young kids they the general
response is what a chump
no kidding I don't think that's a good
thing no I would agree with you Tom it's
it's not a good thing it just shows a
sense of responsibility you know and in
a way just to did it do it do we know
did he hit 300 the next year did he do
that did he get the mom I don't know I
do know a little known fact you know
he's credited with 399 home runs right
God 10 Golden Gloves and he actually hit
400 home runs but one was taken away
because of a rainout oh there's a
little-known fact I don't know whether
he hit 300 up until his very last season
he had a lifetime 300 batting average
and it was his wife had to convince him
to play one more year to get 3,000 hits
he was a proud man but over took
pleasure in his abilities he was a
phenomenal baseball player when you see
the evaluations of guys like Brooks
Robinson and all the people who played
in his day and and subsequently you see
the respect he earned as a player the
other player got 100 grand was Willie
Mays no there you go that makes sense
that makes sense that makes sense to the
two guys and and I assume he got a
hundred grand and I assume he hit 300 he
did for most of his career so his
youngest guy to ever won a batting title
but those are stats more important is
who he was no doubt I do know he wasn't
just you know he wasn't a do-gooder or
just a stuffed shirt because you know
why tell me if I'm talking to no no no I
by the way Tom Selleck here in the
Richard's draw I love all this because I
know he kind of played a prank on you
when you when you went to spring
training I go to spring training and the
next a really big deal he was obviously
knew I was a big fan I certainly talked
about it in enough interviews and he on
his own comes up to me he's in uniform
and he says you want to play catch when
we after we stretched and we warmed up
tonight so I
to play long cost with my boyhood idol
which is a a rare thing but I that I
figured the Tigers kind of accepted me
Sparkie made sure I had a locker with
everybody and I just
they tried not to treat me any
differently they what they treated me
like was a rookie so I I mean I figured
I was accepted because there were
constant pranks on the new rookie like
putting heat rub in my jockstrap
I was they're all watching me and we're
out stretching and I'm just feeling a
little uncomfortable and the whole app
started so I got the point on the smell
and everything I put on I was very
suspicious very sanitary socks anything
and but out comes over one day and he
pulls up a stool and I go and I'm trying
not to act impressed or anything and
then just be normal and I don't want to
gush or anything and he's talking about
me and how I'm doing you know hitting
and stuff and I'm going and I see
everybody staring at me in the whole
locker room and I go boy they're
impressed
Alice Alves accepting me well and every
time I'd look away he'd get my attention
at town listen to me
and so he had my eyes and what they've
done is they put a product called skin
loop in my shoes it goes up it's a
little oh my god they filled it up and I
never got to look at my shoes because I
was in a hurry but I wanted to listen to
how and I just stuck my feet into but if
I'm not mistaken Sparkie did have your
back when he tried to give you an at-bat
in spring training right where yeah what
happened in that one does well he called
me in and he said Tom
we were playing the world champion Reds
at night he
look I'm you're not going to really know
what this is like you know what it's
like hanging out with the players but
I'm gonna get you in at bat he said
they're probably going to find me but
woman what the hell can they do to me so
um he says I'm going to put you in the
seventh inning and you're gonna pitch
hit and so I'm sweating bullets I mean
I'm I'm excited but but scary and I was
sitting on the bench I usually sat with
a great player great guy Dave Bergman
insurance with the guys and I knew him
all by then and seventh inning comes
around and Sparky doesn't even look at
me he just kind of strolls down the
dugout in my direction and as he passes
me he doesn't look at me but says
because the guy warming up was Rob
Dibble oh yeah nasty boy Rob Dental
really hard and grunted when he warmed
up so I'm really sweating bullets and
Sparky walks by doesn't even look to me
but he says in a low voice I'm gonna
[Laughter]
show anybody up which is serving I know
Al Kaline believed in you don't show
people up in baseball and he had talked
to Lou Pinella and Lou said look I don't
mind if you put him in it'll be fun for
everybody be a little change of pace but
don't do it with my clothes or so he
waited an inning and I went in and got
my bat what'd you do well I in there I
think al might have been in the booth
doing the announcing but I hung in there
I my my brush with greatness as I filed
off about four pitches ago I was late I
was late I hit left-handed I throw right
and me and Ted Williams and you know the
ball was going up near right down the
third-base line in the stands and so the
guys in the tiger bullpen told me later
because they were rooting for me I was
one of the team now they thought it was
pretty cold because eventually the guy
throws me he'd been throwing straight
and everything else he went off speed on
Tom Selleck did he go off speed on you
Tom did he really go off speed on he
went way off speed he threw me a knuckle
curve which I like low pitches like a
lot of left-handers sure kind of mid
lower thigh and and by the time I swing
it in the dirt in front of the plate and
the guys in the tiger bullpens up that
was cold
well before I let you go he didn't want
some goofy actor I best not hit when
he's trying to make the club before I
let you go Tom I'm just I'm glad that
you're on the show to talk about this I
know you got season ten of Blue Bloods
on Friday at 10:00 Eastern Time and what
the New York City Police Department is
going through right now is nothing short
of heroic and I'm sure you must have
some thoughts on that subject Tom before
I let you go here well obviously I got a
lot of friends in New York I got a lot
of friends in the NYPD they're doing
their job and all we can do is be good
citizens and do our job but they're all
those people on the line are just from
EMS fire and EMS guys the police
military people especially that
caregivers it's different I got a lot of
friends and I I flew out before they
they shut it down they shut down our
show and I thought because my homes in
California and I thought it needed to be
with my wife so I had a couple of weeks
of quarantine and I'm doing fine that's
great to hear
but you think everybody the only thing I
wish I could do as a citizen if if I was
still there is is open my window and at
7:00 at night bang some pans and shout
support which i think is a wonderful
thing I think it
it says a lot that the people that
police get you know get you get a couple
bad apples and police get blamed for all
sorts of things I kind of know what the
job entails after playing the police
commissioner for ten years and it's what
they do and what they sacrifice and the
toll on on police officers and emergency
workers there's a there's a toll on what
you see that you can't it can't help
affecting you and and it it's it's
multiplied about tenfold right now and
then it just grinds you down so thank
you now thank everybody for their
service and just understand the toll
that that's taken and then they got to
go home their families and hope they
don't get in a second exactly and that's
as well said as possible Tom and I
appreciate you calling in and sharing
those memories that you did and saying
what you just said so very well straight
from Commissioner of New York City
Police Commissioner of Blue Bloods
himself Frank Reagan right there before
I let you go because we're here to help
people sort of take their minds off of
things we fashioned our poll question
today in honor of you Tom Selleck my my
my colleague Chris Brockman read off the
poll question right now we know who he's
gonna vote for but maybe he'll vote for
second place here Chris yeah Tom in
honor of you who's got the best TV
mustache of all time yourself you know I
know you don't get through an interview
without a mustache okay well I don't
need the mustache I was born without it
but who's got the best one besides me
yeah Alex Trebek Isaac from The Love
Boat or Ned Flanders oh gosh you know
what that was a great one but we went
television we didn't go sports cuz we
could have gone Dick Tidrow we could
have gone all that one so so give him
the other choices so we went Alex Trebek
from back in the day Isaac from The Love
Boat and Ned Flanders from The Simpsons
what do you got
would you vote for second place there
Tom I go for obvious reasons and I hope
it's a shot in the arm in his arm
Alex Trebek okay what is a mensch Tom
Selleck right there that's well done Tom
thanks for thanks for calling in you
take care of yourself and hopefully this
will be the first of many times you call
in I'm a big fan
thanks for Donna join it and thanks for
talking about out you got it that's Tom
Selleck right here on the Rich Eisen
show